hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast this is I believe our one
thousand three hundred and twelfth live
stream is that correct that is right
that was what I came up with all right
well we are we are what happens when you
do back at the end of lope math back
yeah the envelope was wet so it I guess
it was a little difficult to do but
number 25 number twenty-five actually
okay good so I thought actually in light
of the way things are going instead of
opening with some kind of a light
anecdote or a story or a joke that we
would instead try five seconds of
violence just to get us in sync one two
three four or five here we go
all right we've gotten that internalized
violence is thought that was oh no
silence is violence pure and simple
there's no internalized at all how did
you miss it
Wow okay yeah yeah okay but anyway now
we're pumped impress ready to go yeah
we're gonna talk about all the things
that have taken place since our last
live stream we skipped one because we
had other material arising but you mean
we skipped talking about the modern
moment as much because because you would
Vanna Rogan and we talked a bit about
the story that you alluded to but did
not talk did not talk about - Joe yes
yes so we have lots of stuff that's
built up in the hopper yeah so much so
much more than then we will get to of
course um can I start by saying that I
listened to your conversation with you
the first conversation that you've had
with John recorder that's up on the Dark
Horse podcast and on this YouTube
channel and it is extraordinary I mean I
hardly know him but I of course have the
deepest respect for both of you and you
know watching two people engage in good
faith around complex issues about which
you don't exactly see the same thing is
truly remarkable I didn't actually watch
it I listened to it as a podcast in the
car but I imagine watching even added a
little bit more more nuance one thing
that came out
you know I've been I've been I have
found mcquarters contention that this is
a religious movement and this is not
really metaphor even though this is akin
to religion that this is like religion a
very compelling argument for years now
and I think it was a 20-18 article that
he wrote that really put it into sharp
relief for me and I was wondering though
whether and you know maybe this is
something you can ask him when you're on
with him next whether he would call the
Cultural Revolution and Maoist doctrine
a religion as well what do you what do
you think you have any opinions on that
yeah my guess would be that he will
think that there is an over a lot of
overlap yeah and I guess the question I
would have is given your in my
perspective about what religion is and
how it came about that it is an
evolutionary phenomenon that this may
actually be an empirical question right
there may actually be circuitry that is
called into play when one goes into a
religious modality and so it may you
know it may be a matter of a brain scan
could reveal whether somebody is in that
mindset or not yeah I mean I guess I
tend to think of religious belief and
you know the tenants that have stood the
test of time
emerging slowly and becoming dominant
over time and so the thing that has
seemed so dangerous about this current
movement that has been you know ongoing
for decades actually but is at fever
pitch right now and similarly about how
ism was that it was this top-down
authoritarian extraordinarily quick
thing and actually if I if I could just
read a very brief paragraph this is this
is one of the books on the cultural
revolution that I've been reading I
don't know how to pronounce the guy's
name he's excellent frank to coulter
dutch the third in a in a trilogy the
cultural revolution of people's history
1960 to 1976 he has on page 168 a
quotation from an office worker who's
remembering 1968 sort of early Cultural
Revolution every morning he says we
would stand in front of this with our
little red books and read aloud a few
passages then waving the little red book
we would say three times
great leader teacher helmsman Chairman
Mao may you live ten thousand years and
good health forever - vice-chairman
lianbao it struck me as absurd almost
like a religion most of us felt that way
as I was to discover after the Cultural
Revolution at the time however no one in
their right mind would dare say so
openly let alone discuss it that seems
so much like what we're seeing now this
the culture of fear that is spreading
and as I have said to you in the last
couple of days and I actually just
tweeted just before we went on I think
there is a close analogy to be made
between Mao's little red book and Robin
D'Angelo's white fragility these these
books are being passed around they're
being waved as badges of True Believer
ship and also as ways to basically
bludgeon those who don't fall into line
yeah I I remember you know and again our
audience will be somewhat tired of
hearing how much of this just echoes
rather exactly what we went through at
Evergreen and a sort of miniature
version but I remember the first time I
heard the term white fragility where I
had made what I thought was a very
careful argument about what I thought
was and was not present at Evergreen and
why it was important that we not not
upend the sciences for example in the
process of you know hunting a
non-existent enemy and a an American
Indian colleague of ours challenged me
and just simply asserted that I was
evidencing white fragility and I thought
wait a minute there's no way to make an
argument in this realm because either I
agree with you but if I disagree with
you then it is inherently evidence that
I don't get it yet and so you know it's
it's you know if she floats she's a
witch right and as I went and as you
lose it's right it's it's all of these
things they're there it is it is rigged
it is completely rigged against anyone
who wants to engage the questions with
with substance yes and it is not rigged
subtly it is rigged transparently and
the basic
point at some level is okay you can try
to wriggle out but we have enough power
to force you to this ultimately so as
you wriggle you will find yourself more
and more punished and at some point
you'll wise up and you'll say ah now I
get it
and you know it's as if as if falling
into place as an ally is actually a safe
position oh there is there is no safety
here there is no safe position no it's
like cannon fodder you're going to be
part of the infantry and it's gonna be a
short ride that's right that's right so
I know we've got we've got a lot to talk
about here but I wondered if I could
show a few photographs that I took just
today during a short walk around a
quaint Portland Southwest Portland
neighborhood of signs on poles so this
is a it's a pretty white neighborhood as
Portland is pretty gentrified I think
it's a little commercial area it's
Multnomah village and within about a
five block area
I took cut 20 photographs and some of
them some of these are not high quality
I'm going to show 14 or so here 14 I
think here and I'd love us to just talk
about them and then at the end it's a
good segue to talk about black lives
matter so Zach if you want to show so
these are again these are posters that I
saw in a about five block radius in
Southwest Portland today on June 23rd
2020 and for those who are who will be
listening and not seeing this one says
black lives matter hands up don't shoot
color is not a crime okay that makes
sense and you've got people drawn it's
you know the artwork is is good it's
interesting and people in masks behind
it so that looks that looks like an
honorable representation of what black
lives matter is claiming to be it's a
warm image of this protest absolutely
let's see next next one so sorry about
the lighting here it's super bright and
hot out here in Portland today a few
simple truths that I believe this one
says no one should live in fear murder
is wrong no matter what uniform you wear
and justice shouldn't be something we
have to demand
I'll be done marching
when I see a change this too I find
completely honorable and it was actually
it was this was in the window of a metal
arts shop and I thought it was actually
going to be like a book art shop
printmaking and maybe they have
letterpress in there but this looks like
a handmade letterpress sign with
completely honorable sentiments you know
all of these things anyone who can't get
behind no one should live in fear or
murder is wrong no matter what uniform
you wear I'm that actually indicates a
problem in the head of that person if
they think people should be living in
fear now now we are moving into slightly
more ideological already memed
sentiments no justice no peace which is
one of the things you'll hear chanted
black lives matter and this is folded so
you it is actually spelled correctly
there with now familiar black lives
first but also you know the herons
reaching up I can imagine this you know
people reaching for justice and trying
to do right so so can I just point out
yeah no telling what was on the artists
mind but that fist and those hands are
not a match those hands are
comparatively dainty and that fist is
robust mm-hmm
I wonder if there's not a subtle message
about what they wrongly call a lie ship
here no that's interesting yeah so that
the anthropological term would be sort
of gray style versus robust forms in
which the gray style forms are the
allies and the robust which is say the
stronger and physically more dominant
forms are the are the powerful ones yeah
and of course one of the things about
being a human is that we have moved
farther away from might making right in
general we have we have been able to do
that through our complex sociality and
frankly through our laws and our morals
yes
alliances make strong but then that
raises all sorts of questions about
these alliances which are created
through this process that we talked
about at the beginning where the only
right answer is yes I agree
and then once you agree you'll get your
orders that's right okay next one
we cannot allow their voices to go
unheard anymore this is a handwritten
sign
hashtag justice for all hashtag BLM
hashtag silence is violence allusion to
what you were suggesting earlier and
then up at the top
hashtag amplified melon ated voices
which that's not that's not a thing and
that's dehumanizing again right this
brown and black bodies trope that is
emerging is dehumanizing as is the idea
of melon aided voices on the other hand
we cannot allow their voices to go and
hurt anymore you know I object to the
anymore the same way I object to the
second a in mega actually it's exactly
the same thing make America great let's
do it make America great for everyone
because it wasn't great for everyone at
any point in the past and this is a
point you have made repeatedly we cannot
allow their voices to go and hurt for
sure we everyone needs to be able to
have a voice in a democracy but anymore
look at the history in this country over
you know since the civil rights movement
and and ask yourself who actually is
being disappeared by the mainstream
media and the idea that there are whole
demographics whose voices aren't heard
and that this is the moment that we must
change that is it is not reflective of
what we have the reality we've been
living it's not it's really not
reflective and I like your point about
the analogy here to maggot there's
something psychological about the
statement in which you are already
rooting for the statement at the point
you get to the twist at the end that
forces you to agree to something that
isn't true exactly and it's really I
think you have to you have to read
through the whole thing before you say
anything about what you think about it
and then we all do this thing that I'm
doing right now nodding along like I'm
gonna not along to you because if you
end up saying something crazy a you
don't tend to and you know in my
estimation but also I can then be like
you know what actually no but you know
we're being asked to sign onto these
things yes we can't allow their voices
to go unheard period yes make America
great
period yeah and it you know the risk of
alienating many many people I have been
paying attention to Tucker Carlson's a
little essays that he puts on nightly
off late and I must say there's
something 25% of each one that feels
like it's pandering to a particular
constituency there's a good 75% of them
that is right on target and I strikes me
as quite patriotic and open-minded and
you know he pointed out the other night
we have elected a black president right
and we can try to parse that any way we
want but at some level the idea that
black voices are unheard is to simply
inconsistent with the history that we
all know and the same thing was true in
every white supremacy is alive and well
at Evergreen it's everywhere we had a
black president for how long of the
color of the car yes right and so in any
case the point for the entire duration
of the black president of the United
States last verse was president of the
college and for a time before and after
that as well right and and you know this
claim erupted full force at the place
where we were dedicating a building to
that president and you know he was there
to speak and he was interrupted in order
to challenge white supremacy it's just
it's preposterous the juxtaposition is
really stark but at the point that you
say something like well I can't sign on
to that statement it's like aha knew it
white fragility great you know exactly
all right next next sign racism and
police violence happen here it says in
the past month alone italics George
Floyd Amidala boy I'm in a butcher these
names Al Manar Barry Brianna Taylor and
Tony McDade have been brutally murdered
by police officers this could happen any
day in our community we cannot remain
silent so how can I help donate your
money in time to contact your local reps
and demand accountability three talk
sense into racist family members and
friends again some of the sentiments
here all right we
this could happen in our community maybe
racism and police violence happen here
what is the here this is in a
neighborhood in a city where there has
been a killing of a black man at the
hands of the police officers in the last
couple of years which is quite
contentious with regard to what the
specifics were and it seems pretty clear
to everyone that there was there was
confusion and perhaps intent on the part
of the young man who was killed these
things didn't all happen here so here we
have the the gaming of the language and
the Flyers where you get you get an
immediate emotional response racism and
police violence happen here right here
are the names of the people right those
aren't here and that's not to say that
we aren't all living in a society that
does have racism and police violence but
this is this is beginning to melt into
actual lies I think so
and it also dovetails with some things
that we've talked about earlier the the
strangeness of the protests at Yale
where Nicholas Christakis you know one
of the most decent people that we've
ever encountered is challenged as is as
if he is vile by people who are claiming
oppression who are highly privileged all
right the whole thing just cannot be
made to add up if you take it at face
value we are seeing protests spread from
the u.s. to other places we've started
to get contacts from our friends in
Britain who are watching a protest it
doesn't make any sense because the
relationship between black Europeans and
white Europeans is not an exact mirror
for what goes on in the US they're quite
different this is palpable to us when we
have travelled there and yet the
Internet is causing this wave of
sentiment I guess maybe I put it this
way because the mechanism of
transmission is contagion right it's not
persuasion it's contagion and because
it's contagious because it's built to be
contagious the point is well what's to
stop it from being contagious across an
ocean if we are as close as
our screens - what's taking place over
there so the little traps that you know
cause us to you know chase our tails
here in North America are also causing
people who happen to speak the same
language to be chasing their tails in
the British Isles even if it doesn't
apply and so this is a huge danger and
at some point I think we need to talk
about people have a an old model of what
to fear and because you would imagine
that revolution would grow from a
central point in some way but in fact
what it's done is it's made a
demographic transition where a lot of
nonsense was fed into a lot of kids
heads in college and those people then
went into institutions it's like Oh
guess what
sleeper cell inside of every institution
of a certain size and a certain size is
like above 20 people yeah and the
nonsense was not just fed into kids
heads in college it's in the k-12
schools and it has been for a while
because the schools of Ed have been have
been captured for at least you know for
at least a decade or more yeah as you
know there's a good essay by a friend of
ours on this which rather than butcher
at the title I will find it and speak to
directly another time but um yeah even
even worse that children not just
college students who are who are
children in many regards yet but actual
children are being indoctrinated
children who inherently by the nature of
children have no mechanism to protect
against what they're being told is the
truth right that we are supposed to
protect them from dangerous falsehoods
at that age so they're open to things
that adults will tell them and we are
now our schools of EDS are now feeding
this mind virus into these young heads
with no defense mechanism and it only
gets worse from there that's right okay
next next poster bad apples spoil the
bunch demand that the Multnomah County
Commissioner divest money from racist
policing initiatives and jails and
redirect funds for housing mental health
services schools and more so let me just
show the next two as well because
they're all in this sort of defund the
police
okay bit I want to come back to the
Apple stuff okay well so let me show the
next to you and then all 245 million one
hundred sixty nine thousand eight
hundred and four dollars for policing it
says no thank you
we'd rather have accessible food
programs Cara not cops PDX
okay on the next one in the same vein
245 million one hundred sixty nine
thousand eight hundred four dollars for
police same question mark no thank you
we'd rather have free public
transportation at care not cop speedy
acts okay go for it yeah well I just
want think something you know thirty
dollars for a family dinner we'd rather
have an Xbox you know it's like you did
swapping these things in here a do you
know what that amount is Carey are you
in a position to evaluate how reasonable
that amount is and also just the idea of
we'd rather have this than that and my
point would be you want to talk about
the problem with policing fully up for
an adult conversation about even
throwing out the entire model and
replacing it with something that works
better but you want to tell me you want
to start by removing the police you're
telling me you don't understand the
first thing about what civilization is
and how it runs and you imagine somehow
that whatever was before civilization
you can return to and you haven't
stopped to think about the density that
we live at you don't understand why you
may be decrying violence that shouldn't
be there and it shouldn't be there but
you have no idea how much violence would
be there if you pulled out the thing
that stops it even corrupt terrible cops
prevent violence by virtue of the fact
that when violence happens cops get
called and the even the terrible ones
are you know maybe the most frightening
ones to encounter so that's right and
and once again here we have an emotional
ploy you don't think we should defend
the police what are you against public
transportation you don't think we should
defund the police what are you against
accessible food programs how dare you I
don't think people should eat you don't
think people should be able to get to
their jobs and their families if they
can't pay for it how dare you say it's
it's an attack on your value
yeah and it is enough to drive a systems
thinker insane because these things
aren't hooked up it's not like a blue
Lego you can swap out for a red one it
is you know it's something totally
different so yeah that the apples one I
do want to go back and say bad apples
spoil the bunch of got to spoiled a
bunch that is actually the original
sentiment now almost every time I hear
bad apples invoked it is invoked in a
way that is incoherent right to say well
it's not that the police are bad it's a
few bad apples suggest that those apples
haven't tainted anything else here at
least they've got that right right the
whole idea is well if you think the
bunch is okay you don't understand the
nature of bad apples they get on the
whole thing but now the question is is
it does that apply to things like police
say yeah right and it's an interesting
question yeah I mean and I think it
would be impossible for there not to be
some effect of having a corrupt
policeman in your midst if you are even
if the rest of the police are not
corrupt that corruption does have an
insidious spreading effect yeah well and
let's just say one of the things that
we're learning relatively late in our
understanding of what human beings are
and how they function is how many things
are contagious including things like
happiness you know you walk into a room
with a dour look on your face and it
actually spreads you walk into a room
with a smile on your face it spreads and
it actually changes the circuitry it
changes your understanding of your own
mental state which is why guys on the
make are so fond of telling women they
should smile more because the point is
if you can get a woman to smile even by
tricking her into doing it she'll think
she likes you better than she actually
does so anyway all of the great dating
advice from Brett Weinstein sorry
no this is I mean this is a point that
we should come back to and you know some
more time too but absolutely but just
the number of things that are contagious
that are now contagious over the
Internet across a notion that make for a
completely incoherent narrative where
suddenly you know police violence
happens here in a place where police
violence may be exceedingly rare yet by
virtue of the fact that here seems like
it encompasses everybody who has a
conversation in a language you can
understand so back to our earlier point
about losing our minds yeah right okay
let's
this is a little hard to read sorry it
may take a while to comprehend your role
and racist problems but keep in mind
that people are dying while they wait
for you and then it attributes this
quote to someone named Jen Winston of
black lives matter this is a claim that
is now simply being trotted out a lot of
the claims and white fragility in the
book that is untestable because your
world your role in racist systems is so
vague
you know what systems are racist what
makes them racist and what does your
role that it is it is untestable and so
we are told and I think actually no one
of these maybe I didn't include because
the picture was bad advises that you
know you can't just be not racist you
must be anti-racist and this speaks
exactly to some of what you and John
McWhorter we're talking about it is the
quote unquote anti-racist movement that
is their religious movement just and
it's it it shows that they're good at PR
right an tyfa if you're anti-fascist
yeah well then if you're anti
anti-fascist you must be pro-fascist if
you're anti anti-racist you must be pro
racist and of course that's not actually
true that disagreeing with these
movements makes you the thing that they
claim to be fighting against because
it's really easy to be claimed to be
fighting against something well I think
we need to start engaging the idea that
these are not terms and claims they are
moves just moves
yeah they are moves this is a system and
if you try to navigate by intuition you
will find yourself it spawn there's no
escaping it so I remember actually the
first time I heard the term anti-racist
it was totally positive okay first time
I heard it was in the four o'clock
meeting at Evergreen
where violence nearly broke out several
times and several on the first day of
the protests that were turning into rise
that's calling for my head I decided to
go to the meeting they complained about
the fact that I was there because what a
guy who thought he was in danger
come to a meeting like this now of
course I hadn't felt that I was in
danger until that meeting but in any
case I was there and several extremely
courageous students stood up to defend
me including several students of color
right your students mice to me I felt it
imperative that they speak on my behalf
which I still am honored by their
willingness to confront a very angry mob
when in fact they would be targeted for
doing so you know a couple of like small
bodied women of color yeah like you know
people who could easily have been at
physical risk even if other people
weren't and one such woman stood up in
that meeting that tape exists you can
look at Benjamin voices documentation of
that meeting and you can see her
defending me and she says not only is he
not racist he's anti-racist and I heard
her say that I thought I'd never thought
to use that term never heard it but what
a lovely thing for someone to say about
you right and now I feel about it
exactly as I feel about feminism there
was a time when I would have said I was
a feminist because I thought what
feminism meant was equal opportunity for
women and of course I'm for that
but obviously feminists frankly the
National Organization for Women thought
enough of you to give you an award to
that effect back when you were fighting
both racism and misogyny on the campus
of Penn the first college that you went
to yep
but you know you sign up for these
things I'm not even sure when feminism
became a term that I couldn't get behind
but at some point it was like no way
right that's not third wave went off the
rails in the 90s again a topic for many
other conversations right but my point
is there's no you can't even just
navigate there's no basis to navigate
other than I want you to write down the
definition I'm not signing onto any word
you can't define um which you know is
all I want a stable definition that I
can refer back to you so that I can't
just say oh no that's not what we ever
met yep yeah sorry
okay here we go this is this is what I
call it don't hurt me well this is a
business that's put up as many of these
as they possibly can hoping presumably
they don't get vandalized now this isn't
a part of Portland that hasn't been
vandalized yet but but one never knows
and just a close-up on one of these is
if you are a person who believes in love
justice integrity and equity for all
people then you know that this work is
non-negotiable says Lela F Saad again
black lives matter so once again we are
being told and we Kosh did we hear this
at Evergreen as well yeah if you do not
sign on not only to our conclusion but
also our methods and everything about
what we are doing and how we are
intending to accomplish it then in this
case you do not believe in love justice
integrity equity for all knows those
cannot be values that you hold if you do
not follow us in lockstep and the bodies
in that one are buried under the word
this this is what work this work you
signed on to this work yes yeah just
okay so here we're nearing the end of
these commit to being anti-racist and
there's a QR code and I'm going to show
you what happens when you link on that
QR code when we get to the very end of
these which is just a couple more commit
to being anti-racist another one donate
put your money where your mouth is
same QR code egos the same place and
before I show you where that goes which
is basically it's gonna show you how you
can put your money where your mouth this
you know thirty dollars for a family
meal how dare you why don't you put your
money to these now I'm that's I'm
exaggerating but your to your point
earlier one final image that I took on
the streets of Oklahoma village in
Portland today Stonewall was a riot
started by black and Latin X trans women
bang bang bang
that seems like an outlier the heck is
that doing Yeah right is that doing ass
so Zack if you could take down my screen
for a minute while I find what happens
to what happens when we click through on
that Kira code here we are okay so Zack
let's pull this back up it's a compiled
list of donation resources that are
supposedly you know
providing bail money among other things
for people who have been taken in and
you know otherwise these all kind of
sound right except LGBTQ specific
organization what does that have to do
with black lives matter well it just
scroll down a little bit and we very
quickly find okay so black lives matter
good black trans travel fund what what
is what is that and then a mutual aid
project developed in order to help
provide black trans transgender women
with the financial resources needed to
be able to self-determine say for
alternatives to travel so this isn't
about black people
it's about black transgender people and
it's not even about black transgender
people it's about black trans women so
this is a point that I'm sure we will
return to because this is becoming
really a little terrifying about the
connection here but let me just that's
not that's hardly the only trans thing
on this list and I say this you know as
someone as I've made really clear so
many times we have trans friends we had
trans students Transit rail transit rare
this is being politicized and and is
tearing down a lot of the important
protections in society so we have the
trans women of color collective the
trans justices funding project and there
are a couple more up there that I oh and
then you know this once honorable
organization the SPLC the southern
property Law Center which has become
quite quite captured so you can you can
take that down now Zack
I do want which is one more thing maybe
as long as we're here before yeah to say
that black lives matter which is what
this movement is supposedly about should
be an honorable movement and so Zack I
guess if you want to put up the screen
one more time here's here's their actual
website this is the what we believe page
of the black lives matter website and
let me scroll down a little bit and
basically they've got I have to find it
sorry here we are that's near the top we
are unapologetically black and our
positioning
in affirming that black lives matter we
need not qualify our position to love
and desire freedom and justice for
ourselves is a prerequisite for wanting
the same for others I'm on board with
that that that seems acceptable to me
especially the first sentence we are
unapologetically black in our
positioning it's black lives matter as
it should be but they're lying this
isn't what they then do look down this
list and find that we have no goodness
where I've no it's up here we make space
right below this close to the top of the
list we make space for transgender
brothers and sisters to participate and
lead we are self reflexive and do the
work required to dismantle cisgender
privilege and uplift black trans folks
especially black trans women again and
then the next one oh we build a space
that affirms black women final in a list
of three when women make up half of the
population and actual trans people make
up a tiny tiny fraction of 1% and then
finally we make our spaces
family-friendly and enable parents to
fully participate with their children
awesome oops we dismantle the
patriarchal practice that requires
mothers to work double shifts so they
can mother in private even as they
participate in public justice work I
don't I'm not sure exactly what that's
referring to but the very next one is we
disrupt the Western proscribed nuclear
family structure requirement by
supporting each other as excited
pamellingson villages how wait keep
going collectively care for one another
especially our children to the degree
that mothers parents and children are
comfortable mothers parents and children
a phrase a number of people have point
out is carefully constructed to exclude
fathers they could be included under
parents but they are not specifically
labeled there for a reason
and the idea that dismantling the
nuclear family is in any way centering
black lives when it's so clearly
destructive of all lives but actually
historically and right now specifically
destructive of black lives in America
shows that this is not what it seems
yeah you can take it off it's not what
it seems so there is a lot to the
question of what trans is doing here and
why trans Trant black trans women is
playing the specific role that it is so
conspicuously evergreen was not a
especially diverse campus racially
racially right it had only 4,000
students total hmm the protest was
involved a couple hundred people who
were very actively involved three
leaders
maybe the three leaders were maybe eight
leaders right maybe maybe I would say
there were a couple hundred you say the
three leaders who showed up again and
again were black trans women you know
the term that at least two of them used
for themselves or bloc transplant last
trans femme so anyway there's just
something demographically conspicuous
about that right there's something about
people who are born male who transition
to female and are black who are somehow
at the very forefront of this movement
despite their tiny tiny numbers this is
to the exclusion even to the extent that
there's all of this very positive
sounding language about supporting these
trans people this is also to the
exclusion of trans people who aren't
black and it is to the exclusion of
trans men who are born female and
ultimate transition male so in some
sense one of the things that's going on
here is that there's a trick of the mind
right to say we are protecting black
trans women women is a protected class
because women have a built-in
disadvantage least strength wise and
also historically power wise so people
who are born into that advantage and
then move into a protected class are a
phenomenon we have to talk about right
what is the proper mental reaction to
this right is it to take the protections
that we ordinarily reserved for women
and to give them to anyone born male who
simply says you know what I'm female and
if so do you expect
anybody to take advantage of that
opportunity who is not doing so on the
basis that they are internally of this
mindset so I would all just mmm of
course there will be people who take
advantage and of course if there is no
hurdle to be jumped beyond claiming now
I'm a woman of course there will be
people who game that and we have seen it
yep
I would also point out that the it was a
gigantic rally in New York I can't
remember if I showed it on the I don't
think you Tod cast but it was a gigantic
rally in New York and basically as far
as I can tell second to the hashtag
black lives matter in terms of the
protest priorities was black trans lives
matter was the hashtag and so why if the
idea is that this is all people who face
oppression why would you limit that to
black trans lives why wouldn't it just
be trans lives matter as a fellow
traveler honestly I mean if if we were
to take them at their word and say that
this is an objection to police brutality
and the continuing in justices in the
courts and certainly historically
racially in jest laws which demographic
within black people has suffered the
most its young black men right it's
young you know black women like all
black people have suffered at the hands
of racist ideologies in certainly
historical and to some extent modern us
but who has suffered the most within
black people it's black men and why then
why then are we talking why then aren't
they focused on a demographic that is so
tiny and so new but actually has a
history with policing and the courts
that can't probably extend back into
even into the 20th century
so at some level it has something to do
with the fact that you know this
mentality this intersectional mentality
creates an unassailable 'ti right the
unassailable attea pens to the number of
categories that you can add together
that you can say are having an emergent
effect and
there's you know it we were talking
earlier about the the fact that these
words don't function like normal words
that they actually function like
mechanisms that force you into
acknowledgment that the whole slate of
claims is right and you know this is
another set like how do you wade into
these waters about transits I mean we're
watching you know
JK Rowling get into very hot water for
saying very reasonable things about the
need to continue to protect women and
that transness does not invalidate that
need so anyway the waters are so fraught
that nobody can figure out how to
navigate them which is creating a
juggernaut well it doesn't it doesn't
strike me as any sort of a concerted
conspiracy but the ability for people to
make the claim that they were trans
absent intention or actual
follow-through with regard to hormonal
or surgical modification and obvious
gender dysphoria you know body gender
dysphoria and having you know most of
the liberal intelligentsia and
mainstream media and academia say oh of
course if you say so yes
was even if not part originally of the
movement that became black lives matter
certainly it is clear the black lives
matter observed that and said ah that
worked what is it that we can do that
can get people to roll over and accept
these things that sound like if you
don't agree with them you must be a
nasty human being that's how it's that's
how it's being done right now because
although until you know until ten years
ago no one had ever heard of transphobia
and in fact transphobia is not what it
sounds like
but no one wants to be called a racist
no one wants to be called a misogynist
no one wants to be called a transphobic
cept trans folk is so clearly not what
it means it doesn't have the historical
manifestation that that racism does and
so people at first like oh I am alright
gosh that's terrible I don't but you
know I have compassion for trans people
and of course what transphobia
at the point that you're accused of
transphobia often what it means is that
you are making the you know apparently
outrageous but actually biologically
real and foundational claim that sex is
real and that we have an uninterrupted
history of sexual dimorphism and sexual
reproduction for 500 million years you
know that's what that's what I mean when
I say sex is real and that is the moment
when I have been called a transfer well
transphobes
a tripwire it's not a word as a tripwire
and there are several of them
transphobes is anything that suggests
any kind of skepticism about any claim
made within a half a mile of transness
of any kind
hmm you've got turf trans exclusionary
radical feminists which is the claim
that you are in fact some kind of you
are pushing some kind of aggressive
ideology to have any doubt at all that
all protections normally awarded to
women should be necessarily awarded to
two men who transition to female which
includes you know not just you know if
fully transitioned trans woman what is
her situation with regard to public
bathrooms and I say fully transitioned
in contrast to someone who's put on a
dress and declared that because they
like the color pink they're a woman
because no they're not but all the way
over here to if you've declared yourself
a woman you get to you get to compete
against women in sport yeah
which frankly that is the reversal of
the honest and wonderful part of title
nine like title nine happened in order
to allow women to compete in sport and
to get some funds to do so and allowing
men who declared themselves women even
if they've been on hormones if they went
through development as men they should
not be competing against women in sport
they shouldn't be it's not fair yeah and
it is the back door on invention of
legal structure is designed to protect a
class it's the unprotected of a class of
people who were protected for in this
case physical reasons now you just said
to me yesterday about the intentional on
protection of the unknown
getting of some legal structures in
California what was this oh jeez it was
now I don't know how serious this effort
is but there was a where there is a
ballot proposition to remove the
prohibition against discrimination based
on race sex gender identity so that
obviously opens a frightening door but
before we leave the the trans question
so you've got transphobes
kind of all-purpose you've got turf
you've got trans medical list and trance
come which as far as I can tell her it's
not my cell why they have a settled list
and trans scum well sighs Chopin Chazz
it's like Chopin Cass there's a there's
an inability to resolve even the label
on these things meaningfully but what
that one means is that if you are a
person who believes that true transness
requires dysphoria then you are also of
some sort of radical belief system and
that really there is no threshold that
would define the difference between true
trans and anything else and the real
point is look you could make all these
arguments but what's really being said
is you are not under any circumstances
allowed to make any counter-argument or
express any skepticism and this is going
to be a hallmark of this entire movement
which actually if I can can we put up
the yet
what do you ever I wanted to put up the
one of these pictures no no no oh
yeah it's a link to the story about the
you Chicago professor okay so here
University of Chicago econ professor
career torn apart after criticizing
defund the police and the basic premise
here is that this professor in good
standing tweeted that he did not think
defunding the police was such a hot idea
and he was investigated and to the
credit of the University of Chicago
they decided there was nothing racist
about what he had said but he would be
my point a this is the University of
Chicago this is the last stand right
this is the college that has done the
best at protecting freedom of expression
it's not like they laugh principles have
been the beacon of hope there's a very
standard this is the gold standard yes
but they didn't laugh off the claim that
he was racist for believing that
defunding the police was a bad idea and
said so publicly they looked into it
right so that's where we are a tweet
which sigh can you just put it up one
more time right at the bottom of what's
on the screen here it shows the
egregious perhaps firing worthy tweet I
just grow up can you show it to us on
the main screen because we can't see
that very at the bottom too bad he wrote
too bad but hashtag black lives matter
per its core organization at black lives
matter just torpedoed itself with its
full-fledged support of defund the
police so yeah it's jaw-dropping because
alright that's it
so defund the police right it's
obviously an ambiguous hashtag but I
would argue deliberately so and many
people will tell you oh we really do
mean completely defund the police and
the police I would say if you are
advocating anything like ending the
police without creating the society in
which the police are no longer necessary
the advance right you are let's give you
a thousand stupid points right you're a
thousand stupid if you think that's a
good idea right now let's take it one
step farther not only do you believe
that defunding the police completely in
advance of fixing society is a good idea
but you think that anybody who is
skeptical of that idea is inherently
racist okay now are you a hundred
thousand stupid if you believe that I
mean it seems to me it's this is not how
you don't really talk no it's not how I
normally talk but this idea is so bad I
mean as we are now discovering in the
cuz right yeah the top caste chop-chop
three shootings one of them three now
fatal yes it has three shootings I mean
completely predictable this is in a six
square block declared nation-state if
its own that's what a week and a half
old three shootings already right three
shootings already and you know we see a
that the people organizing this zone
having a freaking clue how things work
so there's one piece of video in which
they are begging paramedics to come deal
with one of the shooting victims
but there's another piece of video in
which they're actually assuring the cops
out and driving them off of the same
incident and you know the fact is a
you're not autonomous you're not
providing your own medical services and
police services you're doing some other
thing then you're demanding services
which yes I do believe that somebody
who's been shot deserves to have you
know they're still in Seattle is this
the zone is a fiction but I don't expect
the paramedics to go in the autonomy of
the zone is a fiction yes they are
presumably they're not growing their own
food I mean I understand there's
probably gardens at the moment but yeah
you know they're they're using city
water they're getting food from outside
they're getting medical services from
outside you know the money that they
made they're not they're nowhere close
to autonomous and you know more power to
a group that would actually try to do
this but they clearly have no idea what
it actually takes and what number of
systems they're relying on right what
number of systems they're relying on and
of course at the moment that you need
the paramedics
there's not even a thought in their
minds like oh wait we're autonomous you
know yes like well we're gonna drive the
police out you know berate the
paramedics for not coming in and not put
two and two together yeah right that's
perfectly absurd and then we on the
outside who exist in a world of
linguistic traps which we are all trying
to assure everyone that we Harbor you
know no wrong think are suffering from a
totally insane presentation really
depends what channel you listen to if
you're watching you know the sort of CNN
half of the universe you're getting a
picture of the
I can barely say chop with a straight
face given that it doesn't even
linguistically add up yeah
occupied protests tight yeah it's an
occupation and a protest maybe but yeah
you don't occupy a protest but yeah in
any case yeah if you're paying attention
to the sort of left-leaning mainstream
press or nominally left-leaning
mainstream press you get this picture of
it's a festival it's like a party it's a
barbecue it's you know the next version
of Burning Man yeah all hunky-dory if
you pay attention to the sort of left or
the right leaning side you get a
completely opposite picture it's like
people are being shot there's all kinds
of skullduggery and fake downs and all
of this you know it's it's it's partisan
hackery it's partisan it's partisan
hackery and here's actually unless
you're just take a minute here's an
example Zak if you want to show this
this is from a few days a while back now
John June 12th Time magazine tweeted
physicians have joined protests and
cities across the country and an open
letter signed by 1200 health
professionals says protests should not
be shut down over fears of kovat 19
transmission a day later and you know 34
hours later
Time magazine tweets hundreds of
far-right protesters to fight over 19
restrictions to demonstrate in London
I'm sorry but the coronavirus doesn't
care what your political ideology is
yeah this is this is partisan hackery
and how is it that they expect to have
anyone take them seriously if they are
going to put you have this is this is
from you have to read a Panahi for
having put this together you know she's
as I understand a conservative you know
we don't share politics with her but
people across the aisle are seeing this
nonsense and saying what the hell who
can we trust
so I do want to get back to this I don't
know how much more time we have but
people are beginning to get it now it's
not everybody but people are beginning
to get just how dangerous the situation
we're in is and I'm starting to get very
interesting phone call
in large measure around the Dark Horse
duo proposal that I unleashed in full
form or nearly full form on the Joe
Rogan podcast and what is I think
interesting is that a great many people
are concluding that there just isn't any
solution to the catastrophe that is
unfolding short of something like that
so I would have expected it to be widely
dismissed just on the basis that any
novel electoral plan would be unlikely
to work but a great many people are just
simply understanding that if we play any
of the normal cards in the situation
were effectively cooked because for one
thing this movement has understood
correctly just how much power it has and
it is structured to be infused into
everything already so it doesn't have to
work to get there because it's already
there ready to be activated so you know
could the street part of the protest
calm down of course but it's not going
to back off once it's realize that it
has a mechanism to an extract well-being
and transfer it to itself so it's going
to keep going and then there's the next
part of the puzzle which is perfectly
clear which is that there are great many
people who have now been placed on
notice that it is their well-being that
is going to be transferred to those in
the movement those people have every
right to be terrified and that group
tends to be right leaning they tend to
be armed
they tend to be rural and those people
have not yet weighed in so we are headed
for a disaster we're headed for a
disaster in an election year one of the
things tucker carlson said on his
program that really struck me was he
made a plea to vote for republicans
right and i thought ok standard stuff
and his plea was look don't vote for
them because they're all right they're
not his point was it's the only choice
it's the only choice because they are
the only ones who opposed this
right now I don't believe that this is
the right logic but his point you know
he could have given a rah-rah speech
about Republicans it was very much the
opposite and in fact he took the
president very specifically to task for
the president apparently said that why
he the reason that he had not taken some
aggressive action to halt the
destruction of cities at the hands of
the protest was that actually for the
moment he's enjoying watching this occur
all right there's no Trump said Trump
said well of course he did
and Tucker Carlson of course was like
that's deeply unpatriotic you're the
president of all of these people you owe
it to them so here you've got somebody
saying the Republicans aren't up to the
challenge but what choice do we have
because they're the only people who
oppose this thing the president is
essentially derelict of duty or worse on
this front this is a remarkable thing to
be hearing on Fox News it fits with
where Tucker Carlson has been he's one
of the few voices who talks in an
intelligent way about class warfare
right he's been on this beat a long time
so anyway we're lucky he understands the
value of having an intact loyal
opposition right he he knows that the
left needs to be intact and not entirely
batshit crazy or else the right will go
insane in its own way he seems to he
seems to which you know I think I think
I think he demonstrated respect for you
and your and your you know strongly
left-leaning proclivities when he had
you on back during the evergreen
maddening he do he was he was tickled
that you weren't you know Democratic
Party hack hate matter wasn't Hillary
supporter yeah yeah and you know he is
not a Bernie supporter right I was a
Bernie supporter and that was touching
in some way but he thinks you're wrong
you think he's wrong but like but in
terms of like how how can we go forward
as Patriots to make the country as as
strong and resilient and frankly a
country as anti fragile as possible I
don't think he's mostly got wrong ideas
yeah so a he deserves his do a lot of
people gave him a hard time over campus
craziness but the point is all the
people who are
calling us and saying we blew it you
guys were right this is every bit as
dangerous as you said and it's now you
know taking over the country if not the
world to the extent that he was letting
people look in on college campuses and
saying hey this is not a small matter
right he was correct but anyway back to
the original point there is a great deal
of concern that we have been left with
no lever that correctly
either takes the energy of the protests
and points it in the direction of
something productive and not massively
dangerous and so therefore people are
open to things that under ordinary
circumstances they're not open to that
is to say plays that are of an unusual
sort so the point of view of Dark Horse
podcasts viewers and listeners I would
say this is actually going to fall to
you the thing that makes it possible for
us to do something unusual and to make
it work is momentum which will be
generated grassroots so if you are
thinking yes it would be great if
something were to put us back on track
then the answer is you need to add
energy to the system and we need to
start moving very quickly we do not have
a lot of time so with regard to moving
very quickly you're talking specifically
about Dark Horse duo
yes right yep the Dark Horse duo plan
and the Dark Horse duo plan is carefully
constructed to eliminate the usual
objections to what would be called a
third party run in this case you've got
two parties that have effectively
abdicated responsibility for attempting
to govern at the presidential level and
that opens the door to some alternative
plan and the Dark Horse duo plan is
centrist in the sense that it would take
somebody from the left and somebody from
the right and get consensus from them it
is not inherently about centrist in fact
I have no patience for centrist the fact
is the center is where we meet right
those of us who have a position on what
ought to happen to meet in the center to
discuss it and this is that kind of plan
the idea is that at the moment
saving the Republic is the only
priority that should be on our minds and
that is that's the direction we have to
go if we're to avoid an absolute
calamity in the run-up to this election
mm-hmm okay well I think we've reached a
good pausing point yeah we are we have a
couple of announcements and then we will
be back for Q&A in about 15 minutes
yeah so we've set up this what we're
calling a Dark Horse membership at my
patreon so I get a feather high in
patreon and we'll be doing a private Q&A
once a month the first one will be the
last Sunday of this month's this
upcoming Sunday there's a poll up there
that I will probably all read up it for
what time actually is preferred but
it'll be sometime another day Pacific
time so if you are interested in that go
to my patreon sign up at the five-dollar
level if you want to have your questions
prioritized as what is that the answer
eleven dollars are up you also have a
patreon brett and you do these private
conversations with people once a month
at higher higher holds two different
conversations one of them focused on
evolutionary thinking the other focused
on what to do about the breakdown of
civilization and if you if you are
enjoying this share it like it subscribe
to the channel what else I think that's
it oh oh I guess for those listening who
are only listening in the podcast we do
have a Q&A that we don't put on the
podcast after and you can ask questions
in the super chat if you were if you
were listening if you were watching
YouTube during the first live stream and
we prioritize those based on money
amount and then for the second half of
the QA we prioritize those on the basis
of when they come in so we try to get
through as many as possible never get
through all of them but that's that's
how you can get questions to us start
the second half if you're listening on
audio go check it out on YouTube June a
okay we'll see in about 15 minutes
you